Once we've created a workspace
in RStudio Cloud, a great next
step is to add any co-instructors
and teaching assistants to the space
to help us get everything set up from
within our workspace.
We click on the members tab at the top,
where by default we see any current
members already in the workspace.
We can also click on invitations
to see the status
of any pending invitations
that we've sent.
If we click on the add member
button, we see a pop
up asking us for the new members'
email address, role,
and any additional text
we wish to include in the invite.
One thing we need to think about
here is what role
we'd like to add our co-instructors
and teaching assistants as.
Inviting someone as a moderator
allows that person to access
all of the projects within a workspace.
Whereas if we add them
as an administrator,
they will also have the ability
to add and remove students
as well as change the workspace settings.
Whatever we choose,
we aren't locked into that option forever.
Let's look here where I've added myself
as a member to our data
visualization workspace.
I can change my role
by clicking on the dropdown menu
and choosing an updated role
for any member within the workspace.
Adding members in this way is great
when we want to add
workspace members one by one.
Check out our Inviting Learners video
for ways to add multiple members at once.